[Music]
knowing
it looks like they're just about going
to be topping records hopefully soon
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
back it is the wayne dupree show it is a
balmy
well not bomby it's it's a crazy tuesday
it's crazy tuesday going on
that video that you just saw just a
while ago was the president of the
united states being
you know what they said he was rushed
off the stage he just casually walked
off stage
he looked around he's like yeah oh man
really all right whatever so at first he
was like what
he was like what the secret service like
there's been shots he was like all right
let's go when he came back to answer
their questions he came back
like all right let's wrap this up so we
can get back to the conference
one reporter you're like we shook up and
he was like do i
look rattled
and and then the next reporter was like
are you shook up and then the next
reporter
reporter are you shook up
look i don't know what's going on with
the american media i'm all shook up
okay but y'all you're some lazy
mommy that oh my gosh that's terrible
lazy y'all don't know how to have new
questions
y'all don't need your journalism sucks
it's all but it does your journalism
sucks
but the way that y'all keep on going out
i mean
how can you uh uh were you worried how
can you
ask that i mean how many times can you
ask
will you worry or oh oh oh what's the
name of the shooter
what yes he's outside
well is he oh and they asked to ask are
you sure it was the secret service that
shot the guy
oh and he did shoot yes yes that's what
we're being told
oh oh oh oh and and here's one was it a
man or woman
that doesn't even matter dog and then
they're like did you go to the bunker
did you go to the bunker no i didn't
i didn't have time for all that look
the crazy the reason why i say it about
the woman is because president trump was
like he was shot
he would the um the guy was shot is it a
man or a woman
because you know it could be a woman
well nowadays you don't know yeah
hey did you know if you look up if you
look up bruce jenner
on the google no i don't want to do it
no no i'm just saying no i don't want to
look up here
he no longer exists
he doesn't exist he does not exist
when you have money like that you can do
just about anything you want well i
it's the it's the darkness of the world
mama named
bruce his daddy name and bruce i'm gonna
call him bruce
okay caitlyn
[Laughter]
hey did you know he had a wreck uh early
on
down the mountain oh yeah i saw that
he's taking selfies of his new boots
yeah and you're gonna do that what's up
facebook youtube
periscope clown hub parlor and
rt what's up rt what's going on um we
are
live here on the wayne the pre show to
my left your right is miss liabella
what's up lee
hello and over here i'm getting a little
out of control sorry guys
bishop that's right uh ladies and
gentlemen as you know we are
living in the land of anarchy
[Applause]
[Music]
we are living in the land of anarchy um
guy wasn't going to go out like reginald
denny no
oh no not today not tomorrow
run on that horn yeah he was like
hey get off or get run over that's
that's just how it is
uh things are still happening in chicago
uh the the uh from what we were reading
yesterday the
superintendent said that the reason why
that the looters and writer well not
writers but the looters
were out is because they feel
that there's no consequence to
what they do and we've said that on the
show too
they don't feel like there's going to be
any strong arm of the law
so they're going to go out there to
macy's they're going to go out there to
nordstrom's and all these tesla
they're going to go out there to the
east and they're going to do what they
want to do
now some of these people got arrested
okay
but not everybody everybody's not going
to get arrested uh
but to watch uh that superintendent come
out and talk about
uh situation it only lets you know
first off no it's not president trump's
fault
it's not second off the leaders that are
in that state
are hurting the voters and citizens of
that state
because they aren't following the law or
they're not enforcing the law
and that's something i thought i thought
to y'all before we even bring the guy on
if you look at the the the uh on the
left
and the media and some of the people on
the right and how they attack president
trump
they do so because he wants to enforce
the law the laws that are on the book
she's not making up new law
to them it might be new law because they
don't follow
law you know what i'm saying yeah no 100
percent you don't see me crying and
screaming i'm not mad
why because i follow the law it's the
law breakers
y'all on the wrong side you are on the
wrong side of history
you're on the wrong side of the law what
you're doing is taking advantage of
other people
and force the law what
i guess i was under a different
impression because
my entire life i always thought that if
there were rioters and looters
that they would be taken care of like
that night if you came out you broke the
law you would be arrested they would
they would call police forces in
from other cities and other states and
they would just take care of it one foul
swoop and that would be the end of it
i didn't realize that there was such a
long
pyramid scheme of trying to get these
people to stop
i just feel like there's way too much
paperwork and there's way too much
opinions
i thought that this was kind of like a
done deal i thought that we were a lot
safer than what we were
are and that's what's really concerning
to me
i don't get why it continues to go on i
mean i know why now
but you never knew the ugliness you know
i'm glad that you said that because
that's why we do this show because a lot
of people out there are following
cheerleaders and people that are living
in utopia
that are giving messages out there to
make people feel good
they're hiding what's really going on so
that when
these things that are really happening
across the country
is is happening people are like wait
how why what i thought everything was
you know and and everything isn't
preachy keen out there it's not
but it but it's not peachy keenan is
because you have so many
feckless leaders i've said it that
don't want to uh fall in line with the
constitution number one
but they don't want to uh
move it's probably a shortcut maybe
maybe they're looking for a shortcut in
how to deal with their state
and how to deal with their problems of
unions and racism and different things
like that i don't know
yeah mark s on periscope says the cops
hands are tied
i've got a good friend that's a local
cop here
and he's been a cop he's about ready to
retire he's been a cop all his life
and he said yeah these cops it's their
livelihood
it's it's their money it's their
pensions it's their retirement it's
their health care
it's their entire life and if they defy
a stand down order or if they defy their
boss
or the mayor or the police chief or
whatever you're getting fired
and yeah and let me let me clarify i do
understand that it's not the cops
it's not the uh military it's the
governors that are refusing the mayors
that are refusing help
from the feds and they're not directing
their police force on what to do and
they're not asking other police forces
to come in
that i do understand i just didn't i
never thought that a
mayor would be that ridiculous and
stupid quite frankly
to let this continue to go on they have
the power to stop it
right now this second they have the
power to stop at this second
they actually they were elected to stop
right right they were elected to protect
the the uh uh on the people they voted
them in they were elected
to enforce the laws as a matter of fact
and
if it should be easy if you don't want
to enforce the laws as a leader you
shouldn't be a leader
absolutely i mean recall uh
uh fire pitchforks
broomsticks i don't care whatever you
got to do
yeah get them get them out of office and
put some money in there that is going to
care about you and your family
because if there's anybody that's more
important than
than the united states to you it should
be your family
your family should be number one to take
a treat um
and when you look at these leaders and
what they ain't doing then you have to
question yourself
okay if the person i voted for ain't
taking care of
my family then i gotta do something i ha
i have to
i don't care good i'm afraid well i'm
just saying the seattle police chief
just retired
resigned but well resigned but she's
taken a retirement she said
it's starting september 2nd she's done
why then yeah why
well she her pay has been slashed and
she said that she cannot
handle she said this is what her reason
was when it's time
it's time that's what she said city
council is moving
forward with defund the police oh yeah
this council is moving forward the one
city council
was on an interview and he was like oh
he's like we're going to have people
you know that medically will know how to
take care of you
if you have an emergency you know we'll
come out and help you our social workers
will
and then you know if we need somebody to
have a gun we'll find somebody and i'm
like
oh my gosh remind me before i go on
vacation
call the city and say hey have you
defunded the police
because if they have i'm not going on
vacation in that city i don't even want
to drive through it to get to where i
want to vacation
no citizens on patrol police academy
we know we know how this plays out we
saw in hollywood
hollywood made the movie about this
that's not going to work
it just don't work aaron
aaron on youtube say y'alls takes are
hilarious not
trying to be funny though it's true
and you know i mean your your answer is
probably a trollish because
honestly you really don't have an answer
i'm laughing at
at the lunacy that i'm laughing at how
idiotic how insane these these
uh city council members are i i mean we
got aoc and three
uh rashida talib ilhan omar and rashida
talib's been busted multiple times
before she was elected
screaming and yelling and uh disrupting
trump rallies
she's a radical crazed
insane person y'all elected her
and i just i can see why y'all wearing
bifocals mark
mark on periscope says defund
politicians
i tweeted that out two days ago he
formed government as a matter of fact
take away their yearly salaries take
them away
take them away take the pumpkins away
because
everybody knows you don't have to be in
congress one day and you get a lifetime
pension
chase take that away and then
on top of that the laws that they pass
they have to um they should be under
those laws
i don't know if y'all know this many you
probably do because many of you probably
took politics
is the laws that congress passed do not
pertain to congress
no right no they can pass whatever they
want to
they can pass obamacare but they don't
have to deal with do it do as they say
not as they do
yeah right we saw how they opted
themselves out of obamacare
i believe you reported on that i know i
reported on that back when it was going
down
the hypocrisy knows no bounds when it
comes to politicians
and i'm not talking about just democrats
i'm talking about both of them
yeah these republicans you spineless
jellyfish i thought you guys were going
to take the page out of trump's book
and step up follow moses
donald trump standing up to the
pharisees like moses did
and and fight back against the evils of
the world the people that try and put us
under control
put the thumb down on on an average
person take our money
donald trump having to go executive
order to get our
give us our money back well i'm curious
what's going on too now
uh because uh trump right now is behind
closed doors with wolf
and var talking about what's going on
chicago so that's a big time meeting
something's going to be announced
aaron and aaron on youtube said that uh
y'all voted in
barack obama and uh
and the truth is is that a lot of
americans
because i i didn't vote for the dude i
didn't vote i didn't either
uh but america voted for barack obama
because they saw a couple of reasons why
uh first thing is a lot of black people
voted for barack obama because
he he was well he was so-called black
even though he's not fully black he's
he's mixed and for for anybody that says
he's black
and they don't recognize his whiteness
you're racist because you're trying to
cover up his whiteness number two
um his mama's white so
y'all also covering that up um
but number three the democrats did it
for a reason
so that they wouldn't have to have
another black president for a long time
why
because they can say well we already
gave you one right exactly
barack obama's half man half woman and
when i say half woman
i mean it's because he's got that mama
in him
he's got that woman female side and he
that nurtures the hell
and all you all and he brought it out
he nurtured the hell and y'all and y'all
loved it you're like oh so all the bad
things we're doing are right
yeah he became the biggest appeaser
and a bully all at the same time and you
guys loved it
i couldn't stand it from the beginning
i'm just saying
look at who who rides who rides a bike
with a helmet
i'm not even joe biden i'm a gen xer
and we didn't ride we didn't have no
damn helmets
donald trump up in the white house hey
hey
emergency emergency what is it man i'm
middle of a conference
shooting they shooting outside and he's
like okay
go take care oh my goodness
i stepped down all right let's get this
everywhere well you are
crazy
i had three cups of coffee today
all right but no um um to answer
the guy yeah america voted a man america
voted him because
because he ran a hope and lie i mean i'm
hoping
yeah and and when he got in
when he got in people thought
that he was going to fix a whole lot of
stuff and honestly you take your treat
even though i didn't vote for him
and i say this i'd probably say it more
than anything
he probably could have become one of the
greatest presidents ever if he would
have dealt with the economy
he had an opportunity if he had dealt
with the economy and i know this is me
talking now
and and brian and brian just backed me
up but well
leah don't like crockett i'm biting my
tongue right now i'm holding back
i'm holding back i'm holding
a president that spies on a sitting
president a president that gives 375
billion dollars to iran
in palettes unmarked could never be a
good president
but he'll never be the best president
but he's a liar and he's a snake
right but see all that was after i'm
talking about
winning but when he got in they won they
won
he could have become one of the greatest
residents of all time
by returning america back to work fixing
the economy and moving
america forward but he didn't he stabbed
what he wanted to do
he staggered one no it's not no it's not
what nancy pelosi
and harry reid right wanted him to do
they decided because they thought they
were going to be empire for the next 40
years
you remember that they well until harry
reid had to run in with his bookie
[Laughter]
how do you show up to congress with
black eyes
yeah yeah i mean you it was like
i speak i'm gonna resign
i'm i'm gonna resign yeah um
chuckie schumer went to him before he
was the president and
planted it in his head to run for the
presidency you know that right
right right now well when barack obama
promised
a fundamental transformation
nobody anybody yeah no would you say
fundamental transformation whoa
that should have scared the hell out of
everybody yeah well we didn't realize i
mean i i didn't vote for him but
once he started his talk and i thought
oh he's a little
sly talker and the way that the media
just
you know obsessed and worshipped him
they wouldn't i just didn't like it ann
says
and and look and i understand how i
understand how a lot of conservatives
will or republicans would would
dismiss what i just said because
they just don't like barack obama but
the truth is
he would have been if he would have put
a whole lot of americans back to work
he had an opportunity right in front of
him
with the likes that you know ronald
reagan had now let me ask questions
truly so let's say he put all americans
back to work and the economy is booming
and then he made the soldiers kneel and
he sent over the money to iran
and then he spied on a sitting president
would you still now would that have been
negated then
would you have then okay because he was
not true colors joe he was a terrible
president
with terrible viewpoints and he did
terrible things so
he could have become but
with everything that you put in
afterwards with the
you know the transsexuals back in the
military and stuff like that you know
the fundamental transformation is
is is his downfall
because like i said nobody asked for it
number two nobody won
number three everybody was like what in
the hell just happened
and the media right now after
no economy obama after wrecking the
country
after everything you just just said the
media to this day
still says that barack obama was the
greatest president with no proof
if he had a great economy and they even
lie about the recovering economy he had
if he had a real booming economy
couldn't touch him with a stick and
wasn't it rush limbaugh that just said
that
uh obama's highest economy peak was
right now what trump's economy peak is
and we're in covet 19.
so what's that tell you about the obama
economy
slowest recovery and now you got the
media uh loving all over joe biden
loving all over his policies that are
non-existent
saying that he is uh stamina driven
and and all of this and all of that was
like what that sam
hell we see it with our own eyes
and the mainstream media was so happy
that joe biden was riding a bike look he
doesn't have dementia he's riding a bike
dementia patients don't forget things
like riding bikes if they were a good
piano player they can still remember how
to play the piano
it's the short-term memory and the
confusion that gets them
so them justifying him riding a bike oh
my
what's that guy's name brian that like
that you said couldn't fight his way out
of a wet paper bag
baby baby brian stelzner i can't stand
him now he's all my top 10 list people i
can stand
yeah he's the worst and and
just came back i'm not talking since
has nothing to do with the economy obama
is corrupt to the core
so so so when politicians say it's the
economy stupid
but it but ann is saying that it doesn't
have nothing
to do with the account all right okay
all right it's got everything
president trump president trump fixed
the economy
and what are people saying about
president trump
he's the greatest president of all time
but the people who recognize the people
who see or truly foresee
common sense just common sense
non-emotional
they got everybody emotional about obama
because then you get blinded
i'm talking about common sense
straightforward thinking
look at the numbers and the raw data
because
because the economy is what runs this
country
right the economy is what puts money in
your pocket it fills your
fills your refrigerator the thing is
though we kept on having obama run this
country we wouldn't have an economy
because he would have turned us into
something that you would never want to
see in your life
right and that is what their goals were
so really
our good friend charles payne charles
payne on fox news
i've talked to him many times business
fox business news charles payne
voted in 08 for barack obama
charles payne's a businessman i ain't do
it right
well he had a misconception of a concept
and he slipped on some awesome sauce
and it didn't go well he came back in
2012 and said i apologize
i should not have done that this doesn't
make business sense
and it's it's only because the weakness
and the the soyboy
half man half woman mitt romney i think
he's more woman than man
uh that we had him run in 2012 damn you
media
you gave us uh john mccain in 08 we
hated that and the media gave us so
what that what's that unisuit that he
wears under his clothes
oh mitt romney uh john mccain yeah the
ghost of john mccain still haunting
arizona i'm just saying guys it it's
it's been a whirlwind of a ride with
donald trump because we
are at the greatest stock markets are
back
businesses are back let's you know what
let's let's move to uh
uh biden's the vice president
shortlist uh oh yeah pete p raj
and on youtube said biden's vp
shortlist is very scary is is really
scary actually
we already know who his vice president
is yeah
we already know him and we're sure last
week we said last week but first show to
call it
nobody it was for sure now
and ladies and gentlemen if you don't
believe it we'll show it to you right
here
on monday you got bernie sanders and and
then
all the rest of the people uh whitmer
who was supposed to be
uh a nominee a possible vp candidate
she's speaking on money so sh being her
uh clover ain't her michelle obama ain't
her
but all him are on monday on tuesday
aoc is going to get her prime time um
thing
now that's going to be something because
the whole world gets to see how stupid
she is
nice but uh as you can see
that's monday night now here right
monday and tuesday night
this is where we find out who the vice
president
will be for joe biden on wednesday nance
pelosi
and hillary clinton are speaking
elizabeth warren
is missing from the list elizabeth
warren
is speaking so she can't be the vice
presidential nominee because the vice
presidential nominee is later
in the program so she's not going to
speak twice
the vice presidential nominee is going
to speak before barack obama on thursday
just just kind of scan all the way down
there
camilla harris is going to speak before
the biden family
whose name is not on monday tuesday
wednesday and thursday
[Laughter]
so once we saw this and then a little
birdie kind of
talked to us you think you
yeah yeah thank you it's gotta be
yeah thank you leah it's gotta be
something i don't know i mean hey like i
said
my source is sometimes 50 50 sometimes
90 10 but i'm gonna i'm gonna trust her
this time
we're saying it's right she's saying she
told me it's rice right and here's why
joe biden cannot put a vice presidential
nominee that's an unknown
okay not now he's his campaign is such
uh in utter disaster matter of fact i
signed up for the text message alerts
did you yeah they sent me a message the
other day said bad news
trump outraised us by 25 million last
month
oh really good news you can donate right
now
ten dollars oh what so he's got to get
somebody that's got at least have some
kind of name recognition
and susan rice has got it because she's
been all over the media lying and
lying and lying and my friend who i
spoke to said that
uh he is used to susan rice she kind of
gets his flow he has an emotional
attachment to her
she's almost like family from what i can
understand
and he trusts her those were the words
that she used with me when
explaining to me why he picked rice
again she could just be
i don't know but this is what i was
being told he's worked with her for
eight straight years
yeah and uh right she likes where all
them
and also live with obama too look um
why would the vice president nominee
speak
before barack obama when barack obama
shouldn't the vice president shouldn't
the vice president oh
no no no you know what i'm sorry i'm
sorry i it just hit me
um with susan wright's not having any
political experience you got to bring in
barack obama who knows
susan rice so he can talk her up after
she gets yeah
yeah he'll walk out on stage yeah he'll
walk out on stage with her right there
right and anoint anoint her chris and
her say
yeah this is not only is this yes big
paul michelle's a speaker the day before
right not only is this the vp she's
black
she's a woman and she she can't be the
first woman president
this is this is who we gotta go with and
she's she's literally like a
replica of obama she lies the media
she does whatever they say she is their
yes
man kind of person so of course i say
she's worse than obama because she's all
woman
i know she's got nobody there she's all
one
she's got a little bit of dark side oh
no
she's holding to the dark side she's got
some some evil in her
with the likes that i don't think
anybody knows well you know
barack went through that fundamental
transformation so um maybe it's like
superman maybe
barack obama is right maybe that's why
they don't
get together in the same place anymore
if they're not together in the same
place maybe they're the same person you
just don't know
hold out we started the show talking
about the media
we're going to get to the vaccination in
just a few minutes but i
but i just wanted to get my co-host
response
to and and and just remind you
who president trump has been dealing
with for the last
two and a half going on three years be
distributed in a way that
whichever the fastest way there are
various methods and it will be rapidly
distributed
legal challenges with this right i
didn't say that no no i didn't say that
yesterday you said that you were
expecting i said i what i said
is people can do whatever they want i
guess maybe they'll bring
legal actions maybe they won't but they
won't win they won't win
legal action is brought against you on
this why not just work with congress on
this deal
well i'm not saying they're not going to
come back and negotiate they might very
well come back and negotiate
an executive order today and americans
want to know when they're going to see
this relief
very soon they're going to see it very
soon look it's there it is right
there excuse me excuse me there it is
right there go ahead
mr president though this is expected to
be tied up in the court so this relief
is either going to be delayed or blocked
so i think this is going to go very
rapidly through the courts this will go
very
if we get sued it's somebody that
doesn't want people to get money
okay and that's not going to be a very
popular thing go around congress are you
trying to set a new
precedent that the president can go
around congress and decide how do you
hear the word obstruction
they've obstructed congress has
obstructed the democrats have obstructed
people from getting desperately needed
money
go ahead please right here president how
do you keep saying that you
[Applause]
thank you very much everybody thank you
very much
whether y'all believe it or not um
barack oh
where'd he go sorry um
had too much coffee he had to go run
around blocks
he's like sonic the hedgehog whether i
wanted to believe it or not
um trump walking off stage is something
is
some advice that barack obama gave him
a long time ago when they were in the
oval office
and barack oba when barack obama and
president trump were sitting answering
questions
and it was getting too much and barack
obama just stopped talking
and he just told them to clear the room
and as they were clearing the room they
were trying to ask questions
and barack obama said to president trump
you'll learn
that real quick you know
you'll learn how to shut that down real
quick you know that's
you know so him walking off stage uh
and and as you can see uh there's a
whole lot more females now
there's a whole lot more females asking
a question you know why because they're
sorry to say but the truth is the true
the truth
the easy targets meaning or easy
stories where
women say that he's treating women bad
women reporters bad women journalists
babe
if he speaks a certain way to him or
or or something like that it's it's it's
all a setup it's always set up
and anybody can see these things and
this is not conspiracy brian
it's not conspiracy is it just calling
out for
who these people are yeah on uh
twitter's
uh said jim acosta's a woman now that
might be a conspiracy
but there might be no conspiracy that
the women
are in the crowd on classes because
they'll come back
there's a whole lot of men and women out
there boy oh jim acosta is half woman
easily i don't know about all women but
i know he's half something all right
their feelings get hurt so much
ah it's it's a sad thing it's a genie or
gina costa sorry it's gina
uh yeah no but that's that's what it is
donald trump's a racist and they're
trying to tag him as a racist
by saying that going to gettysburg
because he loves the confederates
and then stacking the women now he does
he's sexist he's a racist sexist
and now somehow they're going to get
homophobe
we've reported that president trump is
considering delivering his gop
nomination
acceptance speech from the white house
but amid some criticism of that
potential venue the president is now
floating another one this time
he's talking about the hallowed civil
war battlefield in gettysburg
pennsylvania
but that could be controversial too
particularly because this is a president
who has consistently
positioned himself as a defender of
confederate symbols
and monuments to confederate generals
pam yeah that's a fair point to make
it's a fair point that's a fair point
fair point she didn't even hear what he
said she's just trying to get to the
next
that's what i mean these aren't even
real journalists
wow governor wolf's trying to say don't
come to gettysburg
he said that it'll be a huge fight
there'll be riots
that's what governor wolf is saying i
said it yesterday and i said it
yesterday my scope as well
it is a symbolism for what's going on in
america right now
the left the left the democrats want
another civil war they want another war
either
either uh amen mentally battling for the
minds of the young children
or a physical one just like they did
back in
1863 with with the uh the first
republican president
that abraham lincoln the free slaves
y'all you're on the wrong side
you can do he could do his speech with
those nuns that just won
the case do you remember the the
sisterhood the nuns that just won the
case that they've been trying for
he could do a speech with the nuns and
they'd still have something negative to
say about it so he can't win no matter
where he does his speech
right yeah that's true no and again
every time he turns around either going
to have a reporter
lying a reporter gaslighting a reporter
because they're all in the bag
all these communists have been
infiltrated the
the branch of governor of government
that was supposed to be
for the people reporting on the
government to the people
what was really going on in real time
that is not what's going on now
they're all wholly beholden to paychecks
and
uh globalist and it's sad to say but
damn it
again moses stood up to the pharisees
donald trump standing up to him as well
and look at the look at the fight he's
got on his hands
ladies and gentlemen i uh um
i i just i it's
no wonder no wonder new york gun sales
are skyrocketed
that you know it's it's it's something
when you're seeing all of this mess
happen
and then to learn how new yorkers have
bought more guns in june than
any other june in the past decades wow
as the data shows um the fbi ran
52 000 plus background checks
for people seeking to buy firearms in
the state a
121 percent increase
from june 2019 most
or 31 000 background checks were for
people trying
or trying to buy a rifle hang
guns accounted for about 11 000
background checks in june
research suggests that these gun
purchases spiked in the u.s
with with the beginning of the corona
virus pandemic
after george floyd's death uh let me you
can't find ammunition either
wow you can't find ammo i thought i feel
like that
tonya has uh misconstrued uh what we're
saying
uh no i'm not stirring up emotions about
communism
that is not my goal my goal is to show
you
that communists have completely taken
over the democrat party
and a far fringe marxist
are beholden to that ideology just
listen to him talk
i i i'm not putting words and i'm not
mccarthyism
i'm not putting words in people's mouth
mccarthy had to draw them out of the
shadows
to expose the communists for who they
are and i'll be damned wasn't mccarthy
right after
all now they're coming out of the
shadows and they're saying
i am a trained marxist what
what am i missing yeah
and honestly honestly there's nothing
wrong
with asking somebody aren't they a
communist
right are you and they're not denying it
no no no they're not
america will never be a communist
country
the day does the day it falls the reason
well
the reason why america won't be a
communist country
is two words second amendment america
will not be a communist country
it won't it won't yeah it'll definitely
it's almost like it's almost like um
how democrats tell uh um black americans
they're about the republicans they say
that republicans
want to bring back slavery and they want
to bring back jim crow and they want to
put them back in the fields and stuff
like that
ain't no black person going back in the
fields no
you know scare tactics you're not
forcing a whole lot of black people on a
boat and sending them back to africa
so all all these different types of
words
are stupid if people believe it right
and if anything you should be more
worried about the democrats enforcing
sharia law
on everybody than something like that
because that is possible
yeah wayne you and i've been friends for
for a while now
is anything that i have ever said to you
field white nationalism
oh no and i
um there's a whole lot of things that we
see on this show that are
nationalists yes but it's not it doesn't
have anything to do with white or black
it has no
right right americans because we love
this country that's what a national is
a nationalist is just because the
democrats put white nationalists in
there
to demonize and degrade the
the white people you know that's
that i mean white nationalists and white
supremacists are two different things
in my book oh yeah well if you're a
black
you're a black nationalist asian
nationalist if you're yeah
supremacists and nationalists are two
different things supremacists
hate nationalists love country
to me they're two different things now
i i don't accept what the left
um defines nationalists i don't accept
that
you know why because it's coming from a
hateful party it's coming from people
that think they know what's racism what
i mean you know because they have the
republican code book
you know right well here's the thing
she's
whoever's doing that to you brian is
just trying to trigger your emotions
it's a
it's a trick that the democrats use and
i'm sure then now she's going to say
that you're hurting her feelings because
then that's what they do too
um they take it personally and they they
they can't let things just bounce back
off of them
so then you'll hear that too so it's it
that's exactly what they do
so it's a typical playbook that they do
so just ignore it it's never been i
think in my lifetime it's never been
more
clear of right and wrong and the left
versus the right
and it's because of the democrats the
leaders in the democratic party
have left their people do you know what
nationalism does to a country
yeah it makes it more
it makes the country love itself a whole
lot more
now if you're talking about a crazy
leader that's different but nationalism
makes
the country love themselves a whole lot
more brings it more
america first that's nationalism
to me right and if you're in canada
canada
whatever if you're in mexico mexico
first whatever
we here in america love the founding of
this country
uh judeo-christian values coupled with
uh capitalism
which needs a moral compass that's where
you get it from
made us the greatest country the world's
ever seen in all human history
nationalism makes patriots that's a good
that's a good um national goods
it makes patriots that's very good
um hitler was a nationalist
of the germany that he created
to be he he got people in germany
emotionally charged and angry at the
world
and was able to blind them to believe
something that wasn't
uh that was bad was good and to kill
people but see that's why i said if you
have a crazy leader
right he could turn things in
of in in the direction that he wanted to
go
for himself not for the country
okay he hitler did it for himself
correct
under under the umbrella that he was
joining for the country but he really
did it
to prop up himself um but
okay i got to stop with this guy yeah
maggie are not sheep uh just like the
germans
we are uh clear woke and understood
and we see everything going around us
clearly
donald trump is a president for the
people by the people
even you people that hate donald trump
are going to reap the benefits and the
rewards
of having an incredibly awesome
president
that is uh guided even though you're not
even though you don't want it yeah i
mean
are you taking the money he's sending
you hell yeah send it back oh well then
send it back if you don't like it
yeah and and and and and um turn into a
big screen tv that you get
yeah big old feet those those steaks
you're cooking tonight
go ahead and turn them back too yeah
yeah anything
all the extra stuff that you got with
that big tax break give it back
you don't need it no a little selfish
thing
um like i said
we found out or at least yesterday i
found out
about the vaccine situation in the
vaccine situation
it kind of shocked me a little bit uh
because there is a chance
that states could force you
to get a vaccine vaccination
uh with the punishment of crime um
of being fined or jail time
if that's the way they wanted to go they
could
there's a law that states they can fine
you or give you jail time
if you do not take the vaccine there but
they have to define
they came down as we race to develop a
coronavirus vaccine
some major questions are emerging good
evening
i'm kimberly hunt and i'm steve atkinson
a lot of people are wondering if the
government could force people to get it
or could people who refuse get banned
from stores or lose their jobs
abc 10 news anchor derek stahl spoke
with a legal expert to get some answers
[Music]
imagine a world where you have to get
vaccinated and show
proof to go shopping board a plane or
just go to work
legally it could happen says university
of san diego law professor dov
fox states can compel vaccinations in
more
or less intrusive ways they can limit
access to schools
or services or jobs if people won't
don't get vaccinated
it could force them to pay a fine or
even lock them up in jail
those measures have been adopted in
other countries like france
but not so far in the united states it
all dates back to a supreme court case
in 1905.
the court held that massachusetts could
fine people for not getting vaccinated
against smallpox
that case became the basis of vaccine
requirements at schools across the
country
courts have found that when medically
requires that the public health
outweighs
the individual rights and liberties at
stake just last year new york city
passed an ordinance
fining people for not getting a measles
vaccination but there's a big difference
between what
states have the power to do and what
congress could do
there are these questions separation of
powers commerce clause
questions professor fox says a federal
vaccine requirement would probably get
shot down by the current supreme court
based on a 2012 ruling on the affordable
care act
that means we could have a patchwork of
different vaccination requirements in
different states
professor fox says states would need to
allow exemptions for people with
legitimate medical risks like pregnancy
but
not exemptions for other reasons
religious exemptions philosophical ones
have largely been overridden in the name
of public health however professor fox
says
recent protests over face coverings show
there's a big risk of a backlash here
and just because states have the power
to require vaccinations
doesn't mean it's the best public policy
derek stahl
abc 10 news and legal experts say that
private businesses
there you go they are you well
you know you can get any professor from
anywhere to say anything you want to say
but when it comes down to it when a
rubber uh meets the road
we're not france we're not england we're
not communist china
we are the free united states of america
uh this would be fought in court
and there's there's no way it could
stand people wouldn't stand for maybe
but but but let me throw it back to you
because he also said
that states have forced children to get
vaccinations before they can go to
school
yeah i just got my text message from my
local school that my daughter has to be
vaccinated before the first day of
school
or they will not let her in well they
will not right polio
measles smallpox doesn't matter
you know i think i think those are
that's a whole different family
this covid thing it's a vaccination
period
i mean and they're forcing on the
children right and they're forcing
legally there's no vaccine for the flu
but it is flu shot
but it's legally legally enforced
by states not federal though right
right those are state okay so yeah that
state rep
right so yes in a way brian you're right
states
would be in court but there would be so
many different
challenges for different states because
yeah you could do it in different ways
and and and uh ladies and gentlemen
seven one eight six one eight four eight
three six
if you were to be forced
to take the rascal would would you pay
the fine
and not take it would you would you be
jailed would you
uh resist what would you do 718-618-4836
here's the thing there's a cure there
there are cures
for covid as we sit here now there is a
you know what i want to know there you
are you know what i want to know hold on
we don't need a vaccine for the flu
because there's a way to beat it
we don't need a vaccine for corona
i'm just saying i know you're talking
hydrochloroquine here's my question
i think that they should do a study on
everybody that has lupus that's on
hydrochloroquine and see how many of
them have
contracted chronovirus i would love to
know that
and and you know what and i welcome that
i i just i would welcome it too
i just don't think that hydrochloroquine
is
is the is the end all be all uh um
uh cure okay i have from the security
it being used it being used along with
zinc
and vitamin d there are doctors that
have
lost zero patients and nobody here's my
problem here's my pushback
but then there are also reports of
people that have died because of it
now here's here's my pushback you know
we can't prove that
you there's no proof that people are
dying from hydrochloroquine
it's been used for 50 years and nobody's
ever done for him
not when it's administered properly no
but see you just changed you just
changed
what you said nobody's dying from it and
then you add it
if it's it was because i was thinking of
that husband and wife that started
drinking the
uh the aquarium that was fish tank stuff
828 you're on the line would you
take the vaccination or would you uh
resist
well wayne hello hello brian
hi steve yeah yeah
you're live man you're live terry for 20
years
i've had so many damn vaccines and stuff
pumped through my body um
but as of right now i would refuse
and do anything i had to to not do
um a coded back seat
okay stand in solidarity with you sir
yep
if i if i was forced
[Music]
know get a measles vaccine i would if
i would refuse that because i've already
had the measles when i was a child and i
still don't understand why we're forcing
measles vaccine actually i do understand
it's all about
butts and feet in school equal
money they don't want kids getting
measles being out of school for two
weeks
but once you know measles when i was a
kid anyway
was not deadly in the united states
yeah i had it my sister had it my
brother had it we all had it
never understood the measles vaccine
polio smallpox i still i got the scar
smallpox scar on my arm i'm old enough
to have that
you know i might be able to understand
those because you know those are dead
but measles never was as far as i know
you know it sure it had
some people that would die if they got
it that's because they had other
problems
all right all right well thanks for
letting us know thank you
that's one for the vaccine one for no
vaccine okay
four zero two vaccine and no vaccine
uh no vaccines okay let's do
why why um
basically with the evidence around it
i've actually known about the vaccine
since or not the vaccine but the uh
covert 19 since december
i had friends from china who fled from
that one of them being a doctor
and there's so much misinformation plus
i followed dr john campbell
from the united kingdom who is a retired
professor in that
there's a lot of stuff that is saying
this that we have the means to treat
this very inexpensively
and then i've seen such like with the
ford institute uh research institute
on the actual studies on hydrochloric
and with zinc
uh they've had substantial proof of this
and then there's just been a blanket of
killing this information
right i mean the only and then if you
follow the money
you're talking like with gates
foundation and then the companies that
are producing these vaccines
this is a trillion not not a billion not
hundreds of millions
trillion dollar profit and
it's just insane how dangerous this is
period
i mean look at bill gates is wanting to
vaccinate the entire
planet we need to take up all your time
yeah no bill gates is wanting to
vaccinate the entire planet
i couldn't bill gates wants to take over
the entire planet
[Laughter]
well i don't know about that but i know
that there
a lot of this is boiling down to money
there was a big thing where he was
trying
the gates foundation has uh basically
pushed one of the african
countries down there right to do the
testing or pushing for the coca-19
yeah but yeah and you understand that
but one of the things they're tying into
that was the
electronic tattoo monitoring
and and there's i mean it's just insane
because
this is going along the line as if you
don't have proof and they're gonna and
there's
another side of this tracking system
which people don't realize
it's the monetary side where this will
actually could be used for
uh your electronic monies where they're
eliminating all this right
a lot of people don't realize i mean
this is there's more to this than just
this covet
and the legal legal wise i mean it's
more concerning i witnessed a live feed
from my own state
uh my name is joel by the way i
apologize i didn't introduce myself
but uh my own state where they went and
hello yeah yeah good we're listening oh
over my own state we had a judge uh
basically two sheriffs were
called to shut down a business here uh
in in my own state they brought uh
they cited him thank god they didn't
close them initially down they were
following procedures but they had
someone angry and called about it uh the
judge was saying why didn't you rush
these people and shut it down
immediately
and thank god the sheriff's like well
that's not i don't have that legal
authority to do that right right
right but but but they slammed him in
court saying no you should have did this
and i was just like
what is turning it this is our liberties
and our freedoms have been
right joe and you're talking about
opening up pandora's box in a sense
and i agree with you and so you're
saying uh
no shot you wouldn't do it no shot no
no okay so that's two no vaccine four
three four
shot or no shot
no i'm sorry um eight five eight shot or
no shot
you gotta know your phone number man
what's up you're live
541 you're live go ahead shot on vaccine
or no vaccine
no i wouldn't why
well because i know with bill gates and
house vr
and all they want is money and they want
to populate
the whole united states of america
and i think we should turn it around and
we should give them
and their kids the vaccine shop first
and see how they go
all right thanks a lot man thanks so
much
about look he he said fouchy and
great yeah he said that he knows what
they're about
money and nope nope
he said give them the shots first and
knowing them they'll just
take the sugar water shot this is the
placebo effect
and lie to us
um let's see ryan brian you having
problems hearing
um yeah he's gonna log back in okay are
you taking the shot wayne
heck no but then again
i ain't getting sick sorry about that
brian you want to hear this you want to
hear this real quick
norc center for public affairs research
at the university of chicago
hispanic population community said 23
percent said no
uh african-american community 40 said no
uh white community 16 percent said no
ages 60 16 said
no 27 said not sure uh
56 of the white community said they will
take it
uh over age 60 and older 21 said no
and under the age of 60 35 said no
434 you are live would you take a
vaccinate
would you take a vaccination or no
no not at all i don't think it's
necessary uh
especially considering the fact that so
many of us have already
gotten uh the virus what what's the
point of
getting a vaccine when we already have
the antibodies or we've already got the
virus
up and that that's just one reason why
um i wouldn't support
mandatory vaccine i mean considering who
the vaccines are coming from i mean i
mean these people are known
eugenicists their family members their
fathers
their their eugenicists and you know
running planned parenthood and all this
i mean we know
that their agenda is uh depopulation of
the world
and so why why would we put a
mrna vaccine into our body when it's
never been done before i mean
you know you're just asking for problems
it's just you know
i i yeah i believe if they try this it's
going to start
the second revolution and it's going to
be extremely bloody if it gets to that
point
and i don't want to see that right right
right you make a good point there's
something
i was reading an article yesterday
talking about t cells and when you
uh it's called a herd when you get 17 to
20 percent of the herd
has the virus and then subsequently goes
away
usually the rest of them are fine yeah
that's what happened to the zika virus
right you don't hear about that anymore
no no not at all
because it hit herd immunity that's why
and that's proven
so we'll see that here with covet as
well when we're talking about what
what is it testing up to five million do
we have
five million tests that i believe
something like that yeah we have a long
way to go to get to your heart immunity
but we can do it
absolutely yeah absolutely
so for for those that have called in and
i know there are a whole lot
out there that are that are against
the vaccination and i know president
trump president trump
president trump is is is talented about
touting
vaccinations he's like you know hey you
know we could everybody into the air
stuff
president trump uh a lot of a lot of
mega people
just aren't into that vaccination
they're not
no and the thing is if they say that
you're going to go to jail if you don't
take it
i'm pretty sure when you get to jail
don't they give you shots and stuff
anyways
no no okay that's only in the military
everybody
[Laughter]
some of those people that need shots
they'd be like i need my shot
no give them
[Laughter]
my name is rosie but i'll tell you a
weird story about bill gates
we had a foreign exchange student in my
school
who was very rich he was from holland
and he said he went skiing with
and this is back in like 1998
he told me this in class he said yeah i
went skiing with bill gates for the
summer vacation or
summer whatever it was and he was over
in holland skiing with him and he said
that bill gates said he could control
the entire world with just a push of a
button
that's what bill gates told him back in
1998 we had
we have um eight five eight trying to
get on on the line go ahead eight five
eight
nope 858 just hung up
all right um when you do call
wait for us to bring you in all right
because most nine times out of ten i'm
going to mute you
before i bring you in all right so
um somebody said somebody said tequila
shots only
by jose jose tequila's shots there you
go
yeah uh no no i wouldn't
i'm not taking hydrochloroquine brian
and i'm not taking the vaccination
i believe in jesus jesus is gonna take
care of all
you know no no i'm i'm i'm i'm kidding
when i say that but no i
i i just i just don't believe in all
this stuff
man the the the thing i believe in is
taking care of myself that's it
that's all i'm you know i'm not taking
i'm not taking anything that um
until things have been tested out
properly
i'm not going by somebody else's word on
this map and dc that's not fake news i
was just telling you a story from my
childhood
lighten up
drinking tonic water helps
ward off the mosquitoes for malaria
we got um we got seven zero two on the
line seven zero two go ahead
hi um my name is tanya schuster um i
grew up in the 80s and i do remember um
bill what is it he actually
was trying to remember when he went out
with
oprah i believe and he
was forcing the vaccines over to the
little girls over in
africa and i know they were having
issues with those children because those
kids were actually
on them getting some kind of where they
took their walk or couldn't even have
children
and i really do remember
that incident and that scared me for a
long time
now i know we had to take vaccinations
you know back in
in the 80s which is where my mom made
sure we got the normal ones we have but
bill gates scares the crap out of you
yeah and i just
i mean if you're not a doctor why are
you trying to give
people vaccines when you're not even
qualified for it you're a computer geek
and anybody who takes it
shame on them and then i just watched
one over in africa i was watching the um
i forgot the channel but they gave it to
this
young man and he kind of went crazy i
was actually watching it
on a different kind of channel i forgot
the name of it but it's like an
african town and i was watching it and
i'm like you know what this is
ridiculous you know everybody
should really kind of be take
precautions with somebody like him
i just don't trust him i don't
understand why he's targeting
um majorly black people young kids in
schools i mean it's just ridiculous i'm
so
i would think that america would have
learned by now to stop
the racism stops the other things that's
been going on but
i've never taken that shot and i'm
literally afraid that they're gonna try
to force it on us
and i don't understand why
anybody would let this man do anything
to him
right to them because he's a computer
person i mean what
are you doing what is wrong with
americans
i don't get it and you know what tanya
uh
one thing you know and i'm sure you're
talking about gates as a
as computer geek for all the viruses
that his programs have and software has
he can't even be able to
but yeah with the virus that you know
brian i
i don't know it has it all has to do
with the money
the investment where he's he's got uh
money coming in on the back end from the
vaccines
kind of like hedging your bet in vegas
it is all about the money to this guy he
is absolutely
so evil yep and and as americans it's
like we were taught to
crop up and trust people that have a lot
of money or actresses and actors and i
don't know why
we have to feel like we have to do that
he isn't a doctor he doesn't know
right right
yeah if for those that have fallen
out or don't know christ you usually
put somebody in place of that now we got
all these
famous singers and artists hollywood and
bill gates yeah we gotta let that all go
guys
yeah um do your own research
would you would you take your
vaccination there leah
no i will not no brian
yeah bring it on
yeah right yeah right
brian would be like come on give it to
me give it to me
give me one of those band-aids and say
hcq on it after you're done
you know right right right
all right ladies and gentlemen we're
getting ready to rock out
i want to thank all the phone calls that
we
and for those that didn't get through i
promise that
we will try to get you through we have
until the end of eternity
so um we want tomorrow would be a big
day we might know joe's uh
vp announcement tomorrow which we
already do yeah yeah
[Laughter]
susan
[Music]
but you know honestly it's probably one
of the best things for
trump's base because trump's base
will rally against susan rice because
she's the one that went on tv
and lied to the american people uh
program at the program at the program
blaming it on a
video on benghazi on a video four
americans died because this woman
uh uh no not because of her going on
there
is because she purposely went on tv to
cover it up
she went on tv to cover it up and she
was a mouthpiece a liar
a lying mouthpiece for the obama
administration
and when um obama gets on there and says
well we didn't have any uh
uh problems yo yes you did yeah yeah you
did
yeah you had a lot of problems with the
administration a lot
and uh because antifa and um uh
um um the blm organization rose up onto
you and then raza
under any other president you gave them
space to rise up
you gave you gave that you y'all planted
a seed
for them to rise up and that's what they
did uh
both of them are two parts of the same
coin uh
both sides actually and even though uh
we see some people fighting back against
both of them
uh you know that's that's where it all
started so
uh i don't want to had a better chance
with goya rice instead of susan rice
[Music]
we would have yeah
no you didn't
yeah yeah apparently cheryl teagues
actually bought some goya rice and came
under fire
i'm telling you i vote goya rice over
susan rice anyway
they're good company they are they're
good company
they they believe in god they they talk
about trump
no liars
yeah they didn't have anything to do
with benghazi
where did you get the front did you make
that up by yourself yes i just made it
up right now
i just thought of it that's good just
thought of it
that's that's why she's on the show oh
quick all right um
last thoughts for
leah i want everybody go to
forward slash patreon.com show
oh and we can talk about the app too but
go to uh patreon
dot com forward slash wd show there you
can uh join a membership again it's like
17 cents a day
even if you just take the five dollar
membership uh there's also higher ones
too
if you're film frisky with that and you
can become a member and it helps us
spread the truth
and it helps us continue to do the show
so we appreciate that all of you that
are watching us right now
if we if everybody could just go to
patreon
and and and just check it out just just
check it out give it a chance
everybody that's watching right now or
go and download our new app our new app
is in the app store
download the app check it out send us a
message on the app
call us leave us a message on the app
check out the alarm check out the
traffic check out our shows
check out all this stuff on our app
we're asking you to do that we have
a good 1500 people right watching right
now
we're asking you all to go download the
app or become a patreon member
it's it and and it won't believe me it's
it won't take you 10 15
20 minutes it'll only take you a couple
seconds
uh i want to thank tammy for becoming
a new patreon member yesterday hey
tammy remember the ones in the red like
like like most of y'all have seen
already
are new patreon members since july the
ones that you see with the stars
i still have to fix kathleen but the
ones that you see with stars
are members from two years or more
so they they have they have supported
the show
for two years or more jason has a trophy
at the top he had him and actually
kathleen
are only two 100 members um
you know what two and then we also have
um
more of our patreons right there i want
to add you to this list
i want to add you to the list but i'm
asking you either become a patreon
member
or download the app
write a writer i mean write a review
write a rating
give us a rating whether it's on android
or whether it's on apple
and right now usually i don't beg y'all
for a lot
but i am begging you download that check
it out
yeah that's really cool like he said it
shows your weather it shows your traffic
it sets the alarm for you if you need to
wake up
it is a really fun app and it's easy to
use it's yeah somebody once said or
somebody uh yesterday said oh it costs
money no
it is absolutely free and it's user
friendly it's easy to work so
get on there and check it out it's wayne
dupree podcast is what you'll look up
for the app itself okay
and art art is a follower of mine on my
website
um many of you that go to wayne
depre.com
some a few have uh
complained about the ads uh
google contacted me a couple weeks ago
and they
wanted to know okay since you've been
over the 4 million
page view
limit for the last couple of months what
can we do to help you
google oh so i was like well
a lot of people are complaining about
these y'alls ads
you know so he showed me how
not to get rid of all of them but to get
rid of
some of them in intrusive right
and after i did that art came back
because art wasn't going to come back to
the website no more
all right king back he was like you know
what thank you thank you for doing this
art sent us a donation for the website
um yesterday finally got here here's the
donation
check to help with your website and
broadcast expenses
or maybe these days it would be more
useful in paying for basic living costs
but as
things improving my own work i will
continue to be a contributor best wishes
art so god bless thank you art
for doing that uh we need your help we
need thank you
all right continue doing this we want to
take more phone calls
and just think the more you join us
the more you support us the more we can
expand what we're doing we might go to
two hours we might go to three hours
we might do 12 hours 24 7.
we might need how many of y'all want us
to do 12
hours on election day tell the truth 12
hours on election day we're just taking
calls
interview look at bishop
[Laughter]
yeah so here here is the
yeah so look for your country
bishop that's right that's right
yeah yeah 12
hours on election day okay um brian
what's your last stop
uh prayers for the administration
prayers for donald trump prayers for
safety and prayers for his strength
um you know evil's out there
and uh we've gotta keep fighting back
a lot of people are saying do it do it
on election day that would be cool
for election day yes please do it
brian's
just do it just do it they call you up
brian they called you yeah
drink your coffee and just do it brian
look we got look if that's the case
we gotta take care of our co-hosts i'm
telling you we gotta take care of our
co-hosts
so think about patreon think about
downloading the app
we really want to start moving that app
so that you'll be able to watch the show
on the app if you're not home you can
watch it on the app yeah
you can call us on the app during the
show
you can leave us a message on the app
and we'll get it for the show you can
text us
on the app for the show
you can check your traffic your local
traffic you can check
your local weather it's so many things
that you can do on the app so yeah
all right okay that's enough for me
pushing the app
susan rice is the vice president i will
um will be
the vice president nominee so uh
you heard that you heard that here from
the wayne the pre-show uh my last
thoughts is
uh just remember to keep praying for the
country uh
keep on uh and and and think of your
neighbors
think of your neighbors think your
family think think of your friends
when you are online too because
some crazy people out there and some of
y'all probably get depressed and stuff
for what you see online
but think about those people and
remember they're more important to you
than these people that are trolling you
on your social media page
all right with that said mr brian
out leah out
wayne out god bless y'all have a great
[Music]
evening
you